There's a few women that are going viral right now
because they're talking about my man, my man,
my man does everything. My man,
my man. Oh, my god,
I love my man.
And dogging on women.
If your man's not like that,
oh, girl, you don't know what you're missing.
Blah, blah, blah.
In one of the videos,
the woman literally says,
when we go to the restaurant and I wanna order,
I don't even have to say anything.
He orders everything for me.
He. He already knows what I want.
I don't even have to think.
And it's not because I don't know how, you know?
She's always trying to defend herself.
Another version,
I saw a woman saying,
um, some shit,
oh, when I'm with my man,
I don't have to think.
I can turn my brain off,
and he just does everything.
If I'm moving,
I don't got to worry about the logistics.
My know my man's gonna figure all that out for me,
okay? And where's that gonna fucking leave you
when the relationship's over?
You've now spent five years,
two years, however long,
with your fucking brain turned off,
forgetting how to make decisions.
That's not the wisest choice for your life.
Let's say your man is the most fucking faithful.
He's never gonna get bored of you.
This whole fucking arrangement
where he does all the work and all the thinking
and pays for everything,
that's never gonna backfire.
Let's say he dies,
What the fuck are you going to fucking do?
Women do outlive men.
Men have a shorter lifespan than women.
So odds are you're gonna spend a chunk of your life,
at the end of your life, alone,
having spent all those years with your brain turned off,
not having a think,
not making decisions.
This is not love.
This is just a really fucking cute form of manipulation.
This is just another way to get you standing behind him,
dependent on him for everything,
while making you think you're in control.
You fucking bitches are crazy.
Giving up that much of yourself
to another fucking person
so that you could eat Nana.
You don't know how to cook. You.
The fucking shit storm
that you're creating for your life.
And then call me better. Go ahead.
Call me better.
Call me old,
call me gray.
Call me whatever the fuck you want.
But you're gonna fucking call me one day
when that shit fucking fails you.
Good luck. Woof.